[Music]
he's got a knack for bringing bars and
restaurants
back but with covert restrictions waived
can bars and restaurants be saved
double rhyme for the past year and a
half the u.s
bar and restaurant industry has been hit
with one of the most challenging
economies ever the national
restaurant association reports that 110
000 restaurants closed temporarily
or forever in 2020. so what's it all
gonna look like post pandemic
joining me to discuss hosts of the great
show bar rescue which airs its 200th
episode this sunday
i've seen all of them on the paramount
network the legendary john taffer
john i'm not lying i was tyrus
cyrus and i were both talking about like
we binge watch your show usually on
sundays with a hangover
he'll be cradling me in his arms and uh
i'll be eating
anyway but i have a question for you
between those moments
when you're yelling at someone do you
ever feel compelled to like wink at them
so they don't break down in tears
you know i probably have done that once
or twice greg i must say or a little pat
in the back as i walk by or something
but that wig can sort of bring him back
from the cliff if you know what i mean
yeah yeah yeah you know who i really
hated and i still remember the guy
is the dude that wanted to open a comedy
club in arizona
do you remember him yes and he was the
one who said that comedy doesn't need to
be funny
yes and i proved him right
no but uh yeah he came of that episode
by the way was the meat sauna
yes because when you walked into his
comedy club it smelled like charred meat
yes yeah that would that was a a
challenging episode to say the least
yeah he took his parents money because
he couldn't he couldn't do stand-up and
he bought a comedy club
so he could own the club and hang out
there and pretend he was a comedian
it's one of my favorite episodes but i
digress how do you see the coming year
for
bars and restaurants are you positive
upbeat
boom town yeah you know we take a look
even new york greg
l.a i'm here in vegas i mean vegas was
sold out last weekend
yeah so we're really coming back when
you speak to every restaurant owner
the people are coming back but we have
two problems both
government caused yes you know the
enhanced unemployment benefits
think about this right if it's a two and
larry knows this well if it's a two
household
a two-person household and they're
making 800 each
in unemployment benefits that's about 83
000
a year median household income is only
67
000 a year so you can stay home and
exceed median income
good right now the government is
defending us from getting our employees
back greg restaurants are open two days
rather than seven days it's killing us
the other thing that's killing us
and this goes back to government too
i'll tell you how in a minute you know
those little ketchup packets that we
have
yes those used to cost seven cents they
went up to 11 cents then 17 cents then
30 cents
now it's 40 cents for ketchup packet
now i blame that on the government too
you know why why
ketchup john kerry he's got to have
something to do
yes yes
he's dumping all of it off his yacht to
keep the prices up
by the way a fun little trick if you
don't like somebody you put the ketchup
packets
in there on their under their windshield
wiper
anyway just to put it under the toilet
paper uh the toilet bowl seat worked out
pretty well
sit down slow your leg what do you um so
uh i one of my favorite bars in san
francisco
i'm a tiki bar freak my favorite bar is
the tonga room it's out in san francisco
it's still not open how many places just
aren't going to open
yeah there's a whole bunch greg and the
fact is you know i was making fun with
the ketchup packet but
you know meat is twice the price right
in a seafood it's three times the price
restaurants can't raise their prices
to adjust to that so they're losing
money on every item that they're selling
us now
we're going to lose about 25 percent of
the restaurants and bars by the time
we're done greg
permanently that's a big how can the uh
public
public help in this situation obviously
my solution is always to
drink there heavily and over tip and
then be thrown out
should everybody be you're the perfect
customer
yes so you know greg we have to now be
conscious of our communities and it
isn't just bars
and restaurants it's salons and other
businesses as well
we have to keep our money local yeah if
we don't keep our money local these
local businesses are going to disappear
and they're the flavor the character of
our communities yeah so
you know my advice is keep it local and
be prepared
prices are going to increase yeah and it
isn't the restaurant's choice for doing
it but they're going to go up big time
and i blame it on john kerry i do too
john congratulations on your show
everybody watch it's on paramount he's
got a 200
episode it's a fantastic show once you
start watching it's like potato chips
thanks john